2:00 AM, a few miles outside the city.
The car tore down the asphalt at sixty miles
an hour.
We kept the beams low, the dark road around
us only illuminated by the occasional street
lamp overhead.
Things moved unseen in the trees.
An old song rattled off the radio.
The connection was patchy, so it was interrupted
by intermittent spikes of static.
It was the kind of night when you knew, deep
down, that anything could happen.
You just hoped that “anything” would be
in your favor.
I’d rolled the window down a few minutes
ago, breathing in all that cold, fresh air
to stave off the looming specter of sleep.
Thank god I wasn’t the one driving, or things
would’ve gotten deadly way sooner.
Cops would’ve found us with our bumper wrapped
around a tree, our heads one with the steering
wheel or the windshield, dead on impact or
from the unforgiving cold overnight.
They might’ve even felt sorry for us, until
they found the case.
Perhaps it would have been better that way.
At least it would’ve been quick.
A lot of bad things can happen on lonely state
highways in the dead of night, and we were
about to find out that just crashing your
car was one of the more mild ones.
Scott was driving.
He was also the one who brokered this whole
deal, I was just coming along to provide backup.
There was a fully-loaded Saturday Night Special
sitting in my inner coat pocket, hoping that
it wouldn’t see any action tonight, and
a pump-action shotgun sitting in the back
in case things got really hairy.
Deals like this, you either come well prepared
or reckon with the heavy chance you sure as
hell won’t be leaving.
I never asked Scott how he came into the goods
currently sitting in the briefcase and he
never offered an explanation, either.
He only told me that he’d already secured
a very interested potential buyer from a syndicate
out of town.
Serious people.
Dangerous people.
They’d pay top dollar or leave us tied up
in trash bags in a ditch off the side of the
highway.
But we both needed money, and we were willing
to take that risk if it meant we could return
from this deal as a pair of rich men.
The terms of the deal were simple: We’d
drive out onto a certain state highway at
a little after 2:00 AM with the goods, meet
the buyers at a certain rest stop along the
way, and make the exchange.
We’d then all go our separate ways, and
if we were lucky, none of us would ever see
each other ever again.
Seemed simple enough, sure.
Scott seemed downright chipper about the whole
thing.
And for a little while, I was excited too,
until he told me about the road that the buyers
wanted to meet us on.
We’d all heard legends about that place.
Superstitions, really.
People think criminals are scary, but believe
me, we’re a surprisingly superstitious bunch.
Our profession is one largely based on luck.
Being in the right place at the right time,
and being lucky enough to avoid the cops along
the way.
But something you need to know, whether you’re
a criminal or arrow-straight, is that some
places are always going to be the wrong place.
I’m not gonna tell you which road it is.
I know what you knuckleheads are like.
You’re curious.
You’re thrill-seekers.
Hey, we were all young once.
But if I tell you what this road is, I know
you’re gonna try to find it.
Maybe you’ll even decide it’s worth the
trip down for a pleasant Sunday drive.
Ha!
After what I went through on that road, I
wouldn’t wish a trip down it on my worst
enemy.
There’s no other word for what we encountered
there other than evil.
When we were kids, we used to call it The
Devil’s Passage.
Every spooky rumor and scary story in the
book circulated about that place.
Lemme see what I can remember…
Well, there was the Watcher In The Woods.
People used to say that there was a long,
tall figure with the biggest eyes you’d
ever seen - eyes like headlights - standing
amongst the trees.
If the moonlight shone in at the right angle
as you were driving past, you’d see it standing
there, just staring at you, thinking about
doing who-knows-what.
Then there was Old Beth, the Ghostly Hitchhiker.
People used to say they saw a strange old
woman, hobbling down the side of the road
in the middle of the night.
Sometimes, people said they could hear her
crying, even if they were far enough away
to make such a thing seem impossible.
If you took pity on her and pulled over, asking
her if she needed a ride, she’d tell you
that you were a very kind person, but that
she was fine and dandy walking along by herself.
But if you didn’t stop and offer her a lift,
if you just drove away…
Well, local legend had it that the next time
you’d see her face would be in your rearview
mirror, as she sat in your back seat, reaching
for you with her ancient, bony claws.
It’d make you think twice about leaving
an old woman to walk home alone in the dark.
And of course, there was the Lone Jogger.
The stories my dad told me about him always
used to scare the hell out of me.
He was a pale man, dressed unnaturally light
for the cold winter months, jogging along
the side of the road.
If you looked at him, he’d look back.
If your eyes ever met, the stories went that
he’d start running after you.
It wouldn’t matter how fast you drove, he’d
somehow always catch up, and stare at you
through the glass of your car’s windows.
He never hurt anyone directly, but I imagine
he probably caused a heart attack or two in
his time, if he ever really existed.
But all of these were nothing - I repeat,
nothing - compared to the phantom cruiser.
You had to drive cautiously at night, cause
if you didn’t, you might find a ghostly
1970s police cruiser tailgating you, and that’d
be the worst thing you ever saw.
There were fewer stories about this one than
all the others, because if you ever ran afoul
of the phantom cruiser, chances are that you
wouldn’t survive to tell people about what
happened to you.
Though people could still make an educated
guess about what happened to you based on
whatever was left behind.
Here’s a not-so-fun fact: The Devil’s
Passage is technically qualified for one of
the most dangerous highways in the country.
From crashes to hitchhiker murders to unexplained
deaths on the side of the road, since 1974,
this road has been an incredibly unpleasant
place to drive.
Every time I saw another horror story about
a strange death on the road, I’d think of
the Phantom Cruiser.
And it was those same thoughts polluting my
brain that night, as Scott drove the two of
us to the rest stop halfway down the Devil’s
Passage.
I only realized I’d dozed off when he nudged
me awake, and the blurry lights of distant
street lamps flashed into my field of vision.
“Look alive,” he said.
“We’re here.”
The rest stop wasn’t much to look at.
All that was there was an abandoned gas station,
really the perfect place for this kind of
illicit deal.
My hand moved instinctively to the Special
in my coat and clicked back the hammer.
Something about this whole setup wasn’t
right.
Sting operation?
Police ambush?
This whole thing reeked of a deal too good
to be true.
My instincts turned out to be right, in a
sense, just not in the way I was expecting.
As we turned into the rest stop, Scott turned
up his beams.
All we saw was carnage waiting for us: A car
- presumably one that once belonged to our
prospective buyers - in a state of horrific
disarray.
It looked as though a train had impacted the
side of the vehicle, completely caving it
in.
The metal was covered in deep scratches and
ruts that looked almost like claw marks.
It had been eviscerated.
Scott broke, hard, and we both got out of
the car.
I drew the Special out of my jacket and he
grabbed the shotgun out of the back seat.
We approached with caution, worrying this
might just be another part of the setup until
we saw the thick puddle of blood congealing
under the driver’s side door.
We drew closer, propelled mostly by morbid
curiosity.
Was it a hit from a rival gang looking to
intercept the deal?
It seemed logical, but there were no bullet
holes in the car.
Just ripping, tearing, and massive impact
damage.
Scott shined the light of his phone into the
destroyed car, and I vomited when I saw what
was inside.
The buyers looked less like people and more
like two stacks of pulled pork in tattered
clothes.
If I hadn’t seen them inside the car, I
wouldn’t have even guessed they were human.
And the damage wasn’t just to them: The
upholstery was torn up and burned, with violent
symbols carved into the walls and scrawled
on the cracked windows in blood.
When I turned to Scott, he was ghost-white,
clutching his phone and the shotgun with trembling
hands.
We didn’t exchange a word, but we both knew
it was time to leave.
We could find another buyer.
There would be other opportunities, other
deals.
But lives?
You only get one, and we both silently acknowledged
that if we stuck around here much longer,
we wouldn’t even have that.
We sped back into the car and locked the doors
behind us - for whatever good that would do,
considering the damage that’d been done
to the buyers and their car.
Perhaps we just needed that illusion of security
to get us the hell out of here.
The car pulled out of the rest stop at break-neck
speed.
Scott floored it, trying to put some good
distance between us and the horror at the
rest stop.
Whatever had happened to the Buyers, we didn’t
fancy sharing that same awful fate.
My heart dropped down into my guts when I
heard the sirens and the flashing lights behind
us.
After all this, we’d been busted for speeding.
They’d pull us over and find the guns and
the briefcase in the car, and they’d have
a lot of questions that neither of us would
have good answers to.
We didn’t know whether to slow down and
hope for the best or speed up and take this
boy in blue on a genuine car chase.
This whole thing couldn’t have gone more
wrong.
But my thoughts soon drifted from getting
used to the taste of prison food to something
altogether more sinister: When I saw the car
getting closer in the rearview mirror, I realized
that this wasn’t a modern cop car tailing
us.
It was a beat-up old 70s cruiser, traveling
at insane speeds, gaining on us.
The high beams cut through me like razor blades.
I heard the radio crackle into life, even
though neither I nor Scott touched it.
It wasn’t music, just a hoarse, scratchy
voice repeating the word “Run” again and
again.
And seeing as whatever was behind us clearly
wasn’t a real cop, we were more than happy
to oblige that request.
Scott hit the gas like our lives depended
on it - Which, to be fair, they did.
But no matter how fast we sped up, the cruiser
kept getting closer, like a demon on our tail.
I screamed at Scott to go faster, but we were
going as fast as we could.
Next thing I knew, the phantom cruiser collided
with the back side of our car and sent us
into a spin, showering the two of us with
broken glass crystals as the tires screeched
across the asphalt.
It felt like an eternity before the car came
to rest, and at that moment, the phantom cruiser
stopped too.
Someone got out.
He was dressed like a cop, he even looked
like a cop - a dude in his forties, balding,
overweight, with a handlebar mustache - but
something was wrong about him.
He didn’t say a word as he approached the
car, and he didn’t seem to register me sliding
the Special out of my jacket, either.
He was inches away from Scott’s window when
I panicked and opened fire, sending a hail
of small-caliber rounds into his gut.
He stumbled back slightly, as though shocked,
and then everything got a whole lot worse.
The cop let out the most awful bellow.
Not of pain, but of pure rage.
Something happened to his face: His eyes started
to glow a bright, hellish red, and his jaw
began to extend until he looked like a Munch
painting.
There were no teeth in there, just an infinite,
black void.
He grabbed a dazed Scott through the window,
pulling him into a brutal headlock and dragging
him out of the car, releasing those deranged
bellows the entire time.
Scott screamed and pleaded for help; I grabbed
his body and tried to pull him back in, but
the cop was inhumanly strong.
He just kept pulling until he was all the
way out, thrashing on the asphalt.
I…
I don’t want to tell you what he did next.
Wouldn’t be right.
But suffice to say, I couldn’t save Scott,
and I definitely didn’t want it happening
to me.
While he was working on Scott, I scrambled
into the driver’s seat and floored it, hoping
that Scott would at least buy me some time.
I was weeping in terror as I drove away into
the dark, leaving my friend to a horrible
fate with the driver of the phantom cruiser.
So you can only imagine how I felt when, a
few minutes later, I heard the sirens again,
and saw the bright lights getting closer behind
me.
“Run…Run…Run…”
Now go check out “SCP-002 The Living Room
& the Most Terrifying SCP Rooms” and “The
Secret at the Bottom of SCP-087 - EXPLAINED”
for more SCP videos that’ll give you nightmares!